I run a Yoga Center a block from here
yes and I do everything literally
everything of course any advice is it
bothering you right now can you afford
to hire an entry-level employee to do
the shift that you most hate doing no
but I could work on making more money
too you know can you charge more for
your service
I know you can it's the fear of raising
the price that kills solo entrepreneurs
by you having the courage to walk one
block over and changing the price from
80 an hour to 120 you could then hire
that person and her competitors are not
real competitors even because they're
uniquely you and whoever likes doing it
with you likes doing it with you that's
true there is no [__] competitor we
have the juice the competitor is your
[__] head telling you [__] that's not
true like I can't who am I to raise the
20 bucks that person I think is doing a
good job is ten dollars less
that's who's [__] you up that's your
competitor